hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
today we're gonna be talking about a
little bit stuff about the legendary
loot farm as you may have known with the
recent hotfix that went live on
Borderlands 3 it changed up a lot of
things one being that the trooper broch
or whatever the hell you want to call it
the Chupacabra Box boss and Athena's
that boss does now drop not as much loot
as before and the legendary loot tank
farm that we all know and love the
Jacobs estate has now been nerfed that
loot tank I don't even think spawns
anymore there are a few fixes where you
can turn off your internet and all this
other [ __ ] but like I'm so over
turning off my internet just a farm a
boss or some other garbage so I find
another idea that I've actually been
using for quite a bit and I'm surprised
no one's really understood how to do it
or really and utilized it to its full
effect because it is pretty powerful
yeah so we're gonna be talking about in
today's video so as always looks to be
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
let's get started
so of course spoiler warning just in
case it I obviously don't want to ruin
anything of the game for you or what
this stuff is going to be in the video
but I do recommend that you get to the
very last planet in the game and even if
you're at that point probably just beat
the game at that point as well but if
you have gotten to that point third then
you're not going to be ruined with
spoilers but just in case is a fair
warning but yes you do want to get to
the last planet and that is called
necrosis ale that's where you meet a lot
of the endgame stuff and everyone knows
that there's this giant cube right in
the very middle of the first area and no
one really knew what it did in the
beginning soon a lot of people found out
that you have to shoot each of the cube
sides with each different type of
element that being cryo radiation
corrosion
shock fire I might be missing one oh and
then the kinetic ammo all six I may have
missed one I think I mentioned five but
you have to hit all six of the elements
with you so you're gonna need to bring a
weapon of all sorts I tried to find
weapons that had dual elements like some
had radiation and corrosion but for some
odd reason some of those weapons
wouldn't work on this thing for some
reason I don't know why it doesn't
really make any sense this cube is
really stupid and weird but I just ended
up bringing six weapons of each element
and then just brought that with me and
as you can see I think I'm on mayhem one
I didn't change up the mayhem difficulty
I believe I'm still on mayhem one
because I was farming and I was just
kind of going out throughout and doing
some side quests so this is like the
lowest mayhem difficulty I think it
might even be mayhem too if that but as
you can see it's really not too hard to
shoot one of the sides grab grab the
first weapon you see whatever one you
want to use shoot eat any side that pops
up as soon as the glow swaps to the next
one and keep going if you're on like the
very very last one and if for some odd
reason doesn't happen to light up and
you're for sure that you ended up
hitting it with that element go go swap
to a different one use the corrosion one
again use the radiation one again
sometimes it bugs out I think you'll see
in the gameplay a couple times that I
used in my light Yuda twice even though
you're really supposed to do one element
per square it's a weird cube and it
doesn't really make much sense B as you
can see like two or three Legendary's
had dropped and it really wasn't that
large of time obviously farming that
loot tank was a hell of a lot quicker
and it obviously you could just save and
come right back and get XP from it so
you're obviously not gonna be getting
any XP from this stuff just strictly
just a legendary loot farm so if you're
really in the mood to just get weapons
this is the deal for you then all you
have to do is quit save the game all
that good stuff and then come back and
you will spawn right next to the catcher
ride you can opt to use the catcher ride
and drive up to the area if you want or
you could walk completely fine with me
does not matter and you will spawn on
the new you station with whatever
weapons you had in your slot at that
time so for me I screwed up a lot I had
my weapons that I usually go into actual
farming and fighting for so I had to
redo those every time I spawn so I had
to redo all the the saving and whatnot
sometimes it gets a little bit hectic
where some of the car drivers end up
actually shooting and constantly keep
firing at you if that does happen you
can always fast travel to sanctuary and
come back or quit the game and come back
it happens it's happened a couple times
but it's very very rare you just have to
you can't just overstep your boundary on
them I've been sitting in this area by
this pedestal and they really haven't
touched me even though I've been
lighting up that cube near them the
whole time
and yet honestly that's really it this
Cube has been pretty underappreciated I
feel like it is a bit of a challenge to
open up this cube and I know a couple of
youtubers have tried to cover what the
the solution is and people have kind of
understood
- no one really knows specifically if
like one element is tied to one side of
the cube specifically because it keeps
turning it's very complicated but
honestly this really isn't that hard
it's very underappreciated and it gets
you Legendary's without having to do
anything so you can automatically rank
up and mayhem three rack that [ __ ] up to
mayhem three if you're on a different
difficulty it doesn't matter to me just
rank that up and you'll be getting a lot
more legendary stuff I think mayhem
actually with the newest hotfix
ended up reducing how much Legendary's
you got but I still think you can get
more then it compared to mayhem one it
just won't be the huge amount that we've
been used to like farming grave or
getting five of them from in the looting
getting like five to six and [ __ ] so
it's not gonna be as much but if you do
want some extra legendaries maybe to see
some of the interesting read text
weapons or anything like that this is
the fastest way that I've been able to
find it because these loot tanks ain't
spawning anymore bro if you have a
faster way no issue at all let me know
in the comments below I'll be sure to
test that out just give me some of the
details on how the way you run it for XP
or if you run for a legendary farms on
this newest patch and then let me know
and I'll try to figure it out and if it
ends up being faster the month at I will
make a follow-up video for that and I'll
definitely credit you and all that good
stuff so if you do have that definitely
let me know in the comments below yeah
hope you guys did enjoy this video I
wanted to make it this as short as
possible I don't want to stretch this
[ __ ] longer than it needs to be of
course we have very simple just a quick
recap a very small recap just go to
neckerchief AO in the very beginning
area shoot each side of the cube one
side equals one element and hopefully
that'll work if it ends up not working
and there's that one that just happens
to just not light up regardless of how
many times you hit it with that last
element swap to a different weapon your
corrosion your cryo again whatever ones
you've previously used and shoot that
just in case because sometimes it does
work it makes no sense this cube is
weird but it does work yeah I like the V
if you do enjoy guys subscribed for new
as I said before and hopefully the
legendary farm is good to you and all
that good luck and peace out guys
take care
you
[Music]